few individuals have influenced the
world and many of today's thinkers like
Plato one 20th century philosopher even
went so far as to describe all of
Western philosophy as a series of
footnotes to Plato he created the first
Western University and was teacher to
ancient Greece's greatest minds
including Aristotle but even one of the
founders of philosophy wasn't perfect
along with his great ideas Plato had a
few that haven't exactly stood the test
of time so here are brief rundown of a
few of his best and worst ideas Plato
argued that beyond our imperfect world
was a perfect unchanging world of forms
forms are the ideal versions of the
things and concepts we see around us
they serve as a sort of instruction
manual to our own world floating around
the world of forms is the ideal tree and
the ideal YouTube channel and even the
ideal justice or ideal love our own
reality is comprised of imperfect copies
of ideal forms Plato argued that
philosophers should strive to
contemplate and understand these perfect
forms so that they may better navigate
our misleading reality while it may seem
silly the disconnect between the world
as it appears and the greater truth
behind it is one of philosophies most
vexing problems it's been the subject of
thousands of pages by theologians
philosophers and screenwriters alike it
raises questions like should we trust
our senses to come to the truth or our
own reason for Plato the answer is
reason it alone provides us with at
least the potential to contemplate the
forms but reason didn't always pan out
for Plato himself when he sought to
situate humankind amongst the animals he
lumped us in with birds featherless
bipeds was his official designation
Diogenes the cynic annoyed by this
definition stormed into Plato's class
with a plucked chicken announcing
behold plato's man but back to a few
good ideas Plato is one of the earliest
political theorists on record and with
Aristotle is seen as one of the founders
of political science
he reasons that being a ruler was no
different than any other craft whether a
Potter or doctor and that only those who
had mastered the craft were fit to lead
ruling was the craft of contemplating
the forms in his Republic Plato imagined
a utopia where justice is the ultimate
goal Plato's ideal city seeks a
harmonious balance between its
individual parts and should be led by a
philosopher King millennia before his
time Plato also reasoned that women were
equally able to rule in this model city
unfortunately Plato was inconsistent
with women elsewhere likening them to
children he also believed that a woman's
womb was a live animal that could wander
around in her body and cause illness
this bad idea also espoused by other
contemporaries of Plato was sadly
influential for hundreds of years in
European medicine furthermore he thought
that society should be divided into
three groups producers the military and
the rulers and that a great noble lie
should convince everyone to follow this
structure the noble lie he proposed was
that we're all born with gold silver or
a mixture of brass and iron in our souls
which determine our roles in life some
thinkers have gone on to credit the idea
of the noble lie as a prototype for 20th
century propaganda and the philosopher
King as inspiration for the dictators
that used them should a few bad ideas
tarnish Plato's status as one of the
greatest philosophers in history no
Plato gave the leaders and thinkers who
came after him a place to start through
the centuries we've had the chance to
test those ideas through writing and
experience and have accepted some while
rejecting others we are continuing to
refine amend and edit his ideas which
have become foundations of the modern
world
you